>> CLEANUP ON AISLE KAMALA, THE
VP FORCED TO DO HER OWN DAMAGE
CONTROL AFTER A BRUTAL REPORT ON
DYSFUNCTION IN HER OFFICE.
ALLEGATIONS THAT THERE IS A
NASTY FEUD GOING ON BETWEEN HER
STAFF AND JOE BIDEN'S WHITE
HOUSE.
KAMALA'S TEAM FEELS LIKE SHE'S
BEING SIDELINED AND SADDLED WITH
NO-WIN JOBS BUT THE VEEP ONCE
AGAIN LAUGHING OFF THE
CONTROVERSY.
>> WE'REETTING THINGS DONE AND
WE'RE DOING IT TOGETHER.
>> YOU DON'T FEEL MISUSED OR
UNDERUSE?
>> NO, I DON'T.
I AM VERY, VERYXCITED ABOUT
THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED.
BUT I AM ALSO ABSOLUTELY,
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR EYED THAT THERE
IS A LOT MORE TO DO AND WE'RE
GOING TO GET IT DONE.
YOU KNOW, GEORGE, POLLS, THEY GO
UP, THEY GO DOWN.
BUT I THINK WHAT IS MOST
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE REMAIN
CONSISTENT.
>> ONE OF THE NOIN JOBS HARRIS
HATES BEING THE FACE OF JOE
BIDEN'S BORDER DISASTER.
KAMALA IS PROVING SHE'S WAYUT
OF HER LEAGUE WHEN IT COMES TO
MANAGING THAT PROBLEM.
>> WELL, IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
OVERNIGHT.
WE CAN'T FLIP A SWITCH AND MAKE
IT BETTER.
THE REALITY IS THAT WE INHERITED
A SYSTEM, AN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
THAT WAS DEEPLY BROKEN.
AND IT'S REQUIRING US TO
ACTUALLY PUT IT BANG -- BACK
TOGETHER IN TERMS OF CREATING A
FAIR PROCESS THAT'S EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT.
>> BREAKING AN HOUR AGO, KAMALA
HARRIS' COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
IS OUT AND WILL BE LEAVING IN
DECEMBER.
ALL RIGHT, GREG, YOU'VE BEEN
STEWING OVER THIS KAMALA
SITUATION ALL DAY.
>> YES, I'VE BEEN STEWING AND
STEWING.
THE BORDER FIASCO IS ONE OF THE
GREAT UNTOLD STORIES.
SHE WAS GIVEN A PLUM ASSIGNMENT
AND SHE DOES THIS FACT-FINDING
KARAOKE.
IT'S ALL DONE, PULLS THE PONTIAS
PILATE AND WASHES HER HANDS.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE DOES
WORSE AT CHOOSING NOT TO DO THE
JOB THEY GIVE YOU.
THE CAB GUY WILL BE FOUR, FIVE
HOURS LATE HE WILL FIX THE
CABLE.
SHE'S A CURRENT HEART BEAT AWAY
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S OWNED BY JOE BIDEN.
SHE'S LIKE THE ON DECK BATTER,
THE PITCHER AT THE PLATE, THEY
KNOW HE'S GOING TO WHIFF IN
THREE.
SHE'S THAT OSE.
I LOVE JEN SAKI BLAMES ALL OF
THIS ON RACISM AND SEXISM EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS COMING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, I GUESS THAT MAKES
JOE BIDEN A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
HE WENT TO THE FUNERAL TO THE
GRAND CYCLOPSE, MBE THAT'S
TRUE.
BUT YOU GET THE SENSE THAT IT'S
THE MOST INEPT PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY YET
THEY'VE BEEN IN POLITICS
FOREVER.
THIS IS NOT LIKE TRUMP WHO IS
THE CONSUMMATE OUTSIDER.
THESE ARE INSIDERS OF ELITES
WITH COMBINED EXPERIENCE OF
PROBABLY CENTURIES AND THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THIS JOB FOR DECADES
AND TY SUCK.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
YOU NEED PEOPLE WHO AREN'T IN
GOVERNMENT TO RUN GOVERNMENT.
>> THE ANSWER ABOUT THE BORDER
WHICH IS PRETTY FUNNY.
TRUMP BROKE THE BORDER AND SHE'S
HAVING A HARD TIME PUTTING IT
BACK TOGETHER?
>> YEAH, THIS IS WHAT MAKES ME
REALLY MAD ABOUT DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF THEIR
TALKING POINTS.
YOU HEAR THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
YOU HEAR IT FROM JEN PSAKI.
ANYBODY WHO HAS A DIFFICULT
PROBLEM, ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS --
WE CAN'T WAVE A MAGIC WAND, FLIP
A SWITCH, INSTANTANEOUS.
I GET IT, GOVERNMENT IS HARD
WORK.
FIXING PROBLEMS AND SAVING
PEOPLE'S LIVES TAKES A LOT OF
EFFORT AND ELBOW GREASE AND
ROLLING UP YOUR SLEEVES.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO DO ANY OF
THOSE THINGS.
AGAIN, YOU DON'T WANT TO FIX A
PROBLEM NOW.
SHE'S NOT EVEN IDENTIFYING THE
PROBLEM IN TERMS OF IMMIGRATION.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING, PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING AT THE BDER.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE A PLAN FOR ANY
OFIT.
SHE'S NOT ACKNOWLEDGING IT'S A
MULTIPRONGED ISSUE THAT SHE
SIMPLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE TO SOLVE.
BUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, STAFFERS IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAVE
REACHED CRITICAL MASS.
THEY HAVE DECIDED SHE'S THE
ANVIL PULLING THE ADMINISTRATION
DOWN.
PEOPLE -- VOTERS LOOK AT HER AND
REALIZE SHE'S THE PLAN B.
THAT'S WHY THE POLL NUMBERS ARE
WER.
SHE IS ACTUALLY TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE PAYING ATTENTION
NOW, THEY SAY, I TRUST HER LS
THAN I TRUST THE PRESIDENT.
AND THAT IS SAYING SOMETHING.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING.
I HASN'THOUGHT ABOUT THAT.
AND I THINK ABOUT EVERYTHING.
>> NOT REALLY.
>> THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
>> SUPERFICIALLY.
>> THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE THINKS
THAT KAMALA IS A DRAG ON JOE.
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO GET RID OF
HER.
>> OH, YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S THE ANGLE IN DC
NOW.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT -- I DON'T
KNOW WHO CAME FIRST, THE WEST
WING OR THE RIGHT WING, BUT I
THINK THEY ARE BOTH NOW IN
CAHOOTS WHEN IT COMES TO
CANCELLING KAMALA.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
ABOUT SEXIS OR RACISM, I JUST
BELIEVE IT'S UNPOPULAR AND SHE'S
UNPOPULAR, PARTIALLY, BECAUSE
SHE'S REFUSED TO BEHE
ENERGIZED SIDE KICK TO MAKE JOE
BIDEN LOOK GOOD.
SHE WAS GOING TO B THE
ATESMAN.
>> YOUNG, BRIGHT FEMALE.
>> SHE WAS GOING TO BE THE FIRST
TO MAKE SOME HISTORY.
I STILL SAY SHE SHOULD HAVE GONE
AND STILL CAN GO TO THE EDGE OF
THE RIO GRANDE AND SAY -- DON'T
COME.
STOP, THIS IS NOT WORKING.
MAYBEE SHOULD RESTART THIS
BORDER WALL.
WHATEVER SHE BLAMES IT ON,
WHOEVER CAME BEFORE HER, THE TR
WHATEVER.
>> SHE'LL NEVER DO THAT.
>> WHOEVER IS HER BOOGIE MAN.
IEE'S